how do you sell me the vision when i'm  in the meeting with you or is it the  complete opposite where you say who  cares about a nice car who cares about a  nice house who cares about having a  million in a bank who cares about being  rich who cares about going to hawaii who  cares about going to europe who cares  how do you sell the vision of where the  individual is going and where the  company is going  yeah yeah i i i hear what you're saying  and the way i would think of it is like  do you tell somebody  that they should want lots of money  or do you tell somebody that they should  not want lots of money and my answer is  i don't tell people what they want they  decide what they want  and so i don't really i don't it's up to  them i know in general what the social  science says about human beings which is  the way people are motivated at the  highest level and the way the the people  that make the most important  achievements get find their motivation  is through internal drive